product is no longer as important as the
relationship with the customer
and the company has to be willing to
evolve the product around that
customer's needs
or you know back to that example of
lamborghini sometimes it's just about
the cup holders
which may or may not be exciting for the
engineers to build
but it is what the customer needs and so
this membership economy was really about
designing your offering
for the people you served welcome to 20
minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford you know how everyone today
talks about the membership economy and
how it's taking over the world
well i'm about to talk to the person
that coined the term
meet robbie kellman baxter consultant
author and speaker
robbie is a consultant author and
speaker and she's also the author of the
membership economy and the forever
transaction
and hosts the podcast subscription
stories robbie has more than 20 years of
experience providing strategic business
advice to major organizations
including netflix fitbit microsoft and
consumer reports
she has been focused on subscription and
growth strategies for the past decade
baxter has been featured in the wall
street journal and on cnn
she earned her mba from the stanford gsb
and graduated with honors from harvard
college
robbie kelman baxter thank you for
joining me how are you doing today
doing great glad to be here michael i'm
very glad that you're here talking about
a term that i i
you coined which is incredible and it's
something that i've been thinking about
for a long long time
it's something that is you know a part
of of our ecosystem
so apparently today and i can't wait to
hear about your journey
thinking through it really aggressively
this idea of membership economy
and all these different membership
models that are just exploding you know
in the past
10 years or so you know i as a young
entrepreneur come into this
taking it for granted that we have all
these different subscription models
especially for sas
products but but i guess it's not that
trivial and
i'm excited to hear you know from the
person who one of the people who brought
it to us
what is it and what is it like and why
is it important so robbie take me back a
little bit throughout your journey
through harvard through stanford through
membership economy
you know what what has been sort of your
journey like
yeah so so my personal journey um
you know i i studied uh poetry
in college uh my parents had always told
me that if you
if we my sister and i if we got into a a
really good
liberal arts school we could enjoy it
and study whatever we wanted and that
we'd figure out our career later
not to worry about it um which which
honestly i have now three college age
kids and that's exactly what we told
them
uh because i think it was very good
advice um but
when i started working i quickly i was
very interested in business and i
quickly realized that there were skills
i needed
i worked for the city of new york i was
an urban fellow uh working in economic
development there
and then i went to booz allen to get
some training because the city of new
york really
it was great to a certain extent but
there was no training
um and booz allen big consulting firm
great training
uh and they even told me hey robbie
you need more training you need some
business school because there are just
terms i didn't know there were just
big ideas um that were important to
business that i i kept bumping into and
i i'm
pretty much a self-starter but it was
really helpful to get that
training um and then i spent five years
in tech as a product manager
in silicon valley which is where i live
and where i grew up uh
and i got laid off when i was on
maternity leave and that's when i
started independent consulting so i
reached back to my
exam skills and combined them with my
product marketing skills and said
i'm going to make a living where i
control
the work and the only person i have to
delight is the client who's paying me
um and so i've been consulting ever
since
that's like a little more than 20 years
my fifth client was netflix
uh i fell in love with their business
model and i haven't really looked back
since
and that that's just incredible and i
you know i can only think of
of 10 different places that i want to
take this conversation but i want to
you know i promised myself to to pick
your brain on on
this thing that you've been you know
studying for the past 20 years i guess
this idea of the membership economy so
briefly can you
explain to me really what is this idea
behind the membership economy
and what what led you to even consider
that as some bigger picture idea
that we should all be understanding
better yeah
so it really started with that project
at netflix so i came in
as a consultant they asked me to work on
some acquisition um
programs that they had and i fell in
love with their business model
and what i loved was that they were so
focused on doing one thing well
which i've come to define as you know
the largest selection
of professionally created video content
delivered in the most efficient way
possible
with cost certainty and they were really
focused on delivering on that promise
to their members they had a member
mindset they were focused on the long
term
um and what they got from that and from
their willingness to evolve their
products around that promise
and that commitment to the members and
delivering on a long-term
value proposition is they earned the
right to subscription revenue
and subscription revenue is like the
holy grail for business
and as i was working with netflix i was
in love with the model and i'm trying to
like take it apart and say what's
applicable in other industries i did a
lot of work with
software companies at that time trying
to figure out what's similar what's
different what happens when it's b2b
and as i was falling in love with the
model everybody else around me
was too and i got all of these calls we
want to be the netflix of
you know software as a service we're
going to be the netflix of software
netflix of music netflix of
bicycles we netflix of dental pain
management
netflix of you name it and that's really
where it started and i kept pushing
to try to come up with frameworks that
were applicable across these different
businesses because i saw how powerful
the business model was
at driving profitable revenue
predictable recurring revenue
helping companies understand their
customers better
getting better valuations with investors
and in the public markets
and while a lot of people were coming to
me i was surprised
that not everybody saw what i was seeing
and that's really why i wrote my first
book membership economy which
uh i wrote in 2014. wow
okay so you know if we're looking at you
know even in the tech ecosystem let's
say 20 years ago
and you know during the the height of
the of the dot-com and and we're looking
at it in 2014.
what are key differences what happened
with netflix that you're saying that
you're sitting there and you're saying
wait a minute there's something else
here there is a different
type of of relationship that this
company is building with their
customers that we haven't really seen in
the past 20 years
yeah so what i saw with netflix that got
me really excited
i'd been a product manager in a couple
of different what today would be called
sas companies
so i actually you know knew something
about the world of the world of software
the
world of tech and in most of those
companies
the engineer was king the product was
king
and if a company wasn't using that
product well or using all the features
the company sort of said well they're
stupid they're not they're behind they
don't understand
very much like the way if i drive a
lamborghini off the showroom floor
once i own it it's my problem if i never
take it out of first gear
right that's that's my problem not the
company's problem they've already got my
money
but with the rise of subscriptions
suddenly the product is no longer as
important as the relationship with the
customer
and the company has to be willing to
evolve the product around that
customer's needs
or you know back to that example of
lamborghini sometimes it's just about
the cup holders
which may or may not be exciting for the
engineers to build
but it is what the customer needs and so
this membership economy was really about
designing your offering
for the people you served they were the
members and you continued to evolve that
offering based on what they needed
rather than designing it based on what
kind of
product uh was exciting or fun
to build or what you'd always built in
the past
that makes a lot of sense but it also
sounds to me that another you know
vertical of this is this idea that if
before to sell the lamborghini you had
one touch point where you had to make a
lot of effort to sell it
and once you sold it it's a down payment
for long for
basically the lifetime value you're done
you're done now with subscription models
often on a weekly
monthly or yearly level you have to keep
selling even after the customer saw
everything that you have to offer and
you have to convince them again
it's a much harder sell isn't it
well it's it's a good question michael
because in some ways it's an easier sell
and in some ways it's harder it's easier
because the friction is reduced right
instead of having to spend seven
figures to buy and then customize your
enterprise software license
um suddenly you can configure and
subscribe
right much easier process to get it up
and running
much easier um you know process to see
if you like it
it's but that's the easy part the harder
thing is you have to keep them if you
want to hit that same revenue number
you have to engage them and retain them
so
the big game hunter sales people of the
past
you know aren't as important as people
who can
find the right customers qualify them
well because it's not just that first
purchase
it's the ongoing relationship and the
other thing that's important are the
people on the team
that can continue to engage that
customer on the product side what
becomes important is not just your
headline features
which are the features that get the
customer to buy from you in the first
place
but also your engagement and expansion
features
which are the features that get them to
make it a habit and share it with their
colleagues
so you know i think a big mistake a lot
of companies make
is they think that moving to
subscription or moving to sas
or moving to anything as a service is
just about
repackaging the product same product
different pricing structure
different you know landing page but it's
the same darn thing
and really you have to redesign the
product
in order to be relevant and optimized
for a recurring revenue pricing model
and it sounds like it's not just the
product it sounds like you actually have
to redesign the whole
structure of how you work on the product
and how and what expectations do you
do you set both with your engineering
teams and your and your product teams
because those expectations are exactly
what drives that
you know that innovation cycle over
cycle right
yeah every person i mean it actually i
i'm glad you you pointed that out it's
every part of the organization it
changes how you sell
it changes how you compensate your sales
team it changes how you market your
products how you talk about them
it changes the role of marketing because
a lot of the marketing has to happen
after that initial transaction not just
to get them to buy it but to get them to
use it
and engage and expand over time changes
customer support into customer success
right and as you point out changes how
you build the product itself
so i think if you want the goodness that
is membership
if you want your customers to trust you
to take off their consumer hat put on a
member hat and say i'm going to keep
buying from you forever
you need to earn it with an entire
business system that supports that
ongoing relationship
right and i'm and i'm thinking now but
you know my generation and as
you know we start companies and i'm
watching a lot of my friends
start and it's almost trivial to a lot
of them that of course they're going to
go into
a sas model or into a subscription model
of sorts
because that's it it seems like that
almost in any regard
is better for for you also as an
organization because it almo it almost
forces you to continue innovating right
it almost forces you to keep
to keep being on your toes
yeah it's it's very good it results in
good hygiene
um good business hygiene you're you're
always improving your product
you're listening to your customer there
is a dark side though michael and i
think it's also important to think about
this because
you know i'm old enough now that i know
that you know there's always this
continuous swing from one end of the
pendulum to the other and then you go
back you know
and i'm sure that people are like i have
a great idea what about if you owned it
you know instead of subscribing wouldn't
that be amazing right
and i think that the issues with
subscription one of them is
you tend to get narrower and narrower
and narrower in your focus
so um what i advise organizations to do
is
you want to listen to today's members
but you also need to be listening to
tomorrow's members
as well so you don't you know to use
like a music metaphor
you don't want to just listen to the
violin section you want to be focused on
the whole orchestra
and that includes people who looked at
your offering and chose to go elsewhere
that includes people who used to be
subscribers but have cancelled
that includes people who are considering
you today
um who are still in consumer mode and it
also includes your existing members
uh you'll appreciate this i had a client
that
a long time association been around for
a hundred years um
they had a guy whose job was to do
faxing
you know like a fax machine this is two
years ago
wow and i said they were talking about
how resources were tight and they really
wanted to be more connected with their
members
and they wanted to do a lot of digital
things but they just didn't have the
resources and i said well
get rid of the facts guy right and get
an
email guy like get a growth person right
and they were like well he doesn't want
to do email he likes doing faxing
right and this is serious and they said
and we have several members including
one of our
governing board directors who like
receiving faxes so everybody who liked
receiving faxes was over 70
right and it was taking a whole job out
of a relatively small organization of
you know 50 to 100 people
and you know i said to them it's great
that you're listening to your members
but and it's great that you're listening
to your employees but you gotta
listen to tomorrow's members as well and
none of tomorrow's members are clamoring
for a fax machine right and so where
where are we headed from here
that's a perfect segue and i think that
you know i'm starting to understand a
little bit better
you know it's not just it's not just
that you know young entrepreneurs are
coming and they're challenging the
incumbents because they're a little bit
you know more innovative
or they're faster but it's also just
because naturally they're they're
tending towards
a different model completely where
incumbents have a more difficult time
transitioning even though even if they
understand that they should because of
similar factors
but but what can i be expecting you know
in your mind in the next
10 15 years where are we headed you know
as an economy together
what's happening here yeah so what what
i think is really
exciting is that um organizations are
doing a better job of aligning
the value that the customers receive
with the way that they're charged so you
know if you buy
a car let's say right that might not be
the ideal way to buy a bundle of value
right because
you know you may not need the trunk
because you may not have a lot of stuff
to carry around you may not ever need a
passenger seat because you don't have
passengers
and you may find it very annoying and
uncomfortable to have to find a parking
space
in the city for the car that you only
use on weekends
right so a subscription to let's say
zipcar allows you to unbundle those
things and then find something else you
want a subscription to zipcar
a bus pass a bicycle what have you
i think i'm seeing organizations take it
even a step further so there's
subscription but there are other ways of
providing value
um usage based value um
you know sharing economy value where you
know we're sharing
access to our stored value like i have a
car that's sitting in the parking lot
you live next door to me
why don't you drive it and you can pay
me a little something um
and that way we're both happier uh so so
i think
organizations need to continue to think
about what's the value that my members
want
and how can i optimize my offering to
provide the right bundle of benefits
to this audience so really optimizing
your offering around a group of people
as opposed to optimizing your group of
people around the product
and we're seeing in in china for example
a lot of businesses where
they build the relationship with the
customer first and then they sell they
continue to layer in more and more value
you know first it might be a chatting
app and then it might be
a billing platform and then it might be
a dating site and then it might be
you know commerce um but it's the same
person saying i know
this person very well and i'm going to
keep layering in value and i think
that's where we're going
and and it sounds to me that we can
pretty much sum up a lot of this
conversation around the idea of trust
and i you know going back to the netflix
example i can i can simply imagine
netflix
tomorrow announcing that they're going
into education and providing you know
online schooling
i would trust i would i would enroll
myself no questions asked
even though it has not their ability to
provide educational courses has nothing
to do with their ability to produce
movies
you know on the paper but i as a member
with the trust that i have i i
completely understand this and i think
it's fascinating robbie
i know how busy and i really thank you
for taking the time to be here and i can
i can't wait to read
the books myself but i have a few fun
questions if you're ready for them
okay all right we'll start off easy
what was your favorite subject in school
perhaps even when you were a girl scout
what was your favorite subject you know
going to class
so first of all i loved school um and
i loved all my classes i think what was
interesting to me in hindsight
is that i loved the class with the best
teacher whoever that was so some years
that was english
that was kind of what i really liked the
most if i had a good teacher but if i
didn't have a good english teacher
i liked math and i also had a great
german teacher so i liked
german as well but always about the
teacher more than the subject
i i love that and i completely agree all
right second question
one of your role models if you look back
throughout your career or personal life
who who is somebody that you always
looked up to whether it's real or
fake oh definitely my dad
um so my dad was grew up in brooklyn new
york
um went to law school in new york uh st
john's um
which is uh you know a small small law
school in new york
and then um he worked for i think five
years at a company
at a big wall street law firm and then
he and two of his friends decided they
were gonna start a california
uh wall street style law firm and they
were all gonna move to california
because one of them had gone to stanford
and so my dad who had never been to
california
sent my mom and i was foreign my sister
was one they had no safety net
he sent her out to california to buy a
house and then started a law firm
most conservative person i know but was
willing to take these big risks
um and he's the person that i admire the
most and also
um he's continued to innovate you know
he did the law firm for 30 years and
then he started a venture firm
uh in his 60s you know
a brand new career uh so he's definitely
um my my role model i i love it
okay and robbie the hardest but but not
the most important question
but one that i still love nevertheless
three words that you would choose to
describe yourself
or if i were to ask anybody who who's
robbie
kellman baxter yeah i think they'd say
um
curious motivated
and a connector or connected
curious because there's so many things i
find interesting
motivated because you know my kids are
like do you ever stop working like i
love to work for fun i like to work
and um connected because meeting people
and exchanging ideas is what
keeps me going i love it robbie thank
you
so so much i i truly appreciate you
taking the time for this i loved
all the examples that we talked about
and i know that there was you know a ton
more that we had in store and i can
think of 50 more questions that i want
to ask you but we'll leave that for
another episode and i
i want to thank you for taking the time
i know how biz you are thank you very
much
oh great time uh it was really fun
talking to you great questions too
take care bye
[Music]